앞으로 저는 여기서 더 붙여서 하고
싶어요 우리
한국
뭔가 전통적인 이런 중개업체도 이런
사업을 할 수 있다 해외로 진출할 수
있다라는 거를 좀 보여주고 싶습니다
[음악]
벌써 2023년이 하반기에
진입했는데 상반기에 좀
뭘 했는지 좀
근황토크를 하는 시간을
갖도록 하겠습니다 올해 초에 좀
시장이 많이 안 좋았어요 1월 달에
거래량이 좀 많이 줄었었고이 시기를
잘 이겨내서 장이 좋아졌을 때 좀
어떻게
하는게 좋을지 1 2월달에 좀 생각을
많이 했었던 것 같고 2월 달에 좀
생각을 했던게 제가 부산지사를 한 몇
년 전부터 생각은 하고 있었어요
부산지사를 설립하고 싶다라고 아마
유튜브도 찍고 뭐 sns에도 올렸는데
연락이 생각보다 많이 왔습니다 그때
이제 또 좋으신 분을 만나서 지금
부산지사도 설립해서 최근에 또
계약도 했고
그래도 성과가 조금씩 나고 있습니다
그 다음에 이제 뉴욕도
각이 거의 한 2주 전에 제가
영상이랑 글을 올렸는데 미국에서 좀
연락이 왔었어요 그때 만났던 그 미국
중개업
얘기가 잘 돼서
요번 달에 이제 출국을 하거든요
그래서 이번 달에 가서
mou도 체결할 예정입니다 미국은
사실 저희가 진입할 때 많은 분들이
미국을 어떻게 진출해 미국 너희가
시장을 어떻게 해 이렇게 생각하실
수도 있지만 어떻게 될지 모르거든요
그리고 미국 시장은 지금 저희 한국
시장보다 더 크기 때문에 거기서 좀
저는 좀 성공을 하고 싶습니다 제
개인적으로이 업을
하면서 우리나라 1등뿐만 아니라
세계적인 1등이 되고 싶어요 그
다음에
한국인들이 이제 뉴욕 투자하는 것뿐만
아니라
뉴욕에 계신 분들이 한국 부동산을
투자할 수도 있거든요 그런 쪽에 조금
기회가 있지 않을까
그렇게 생각을 하고 있습니다 저희가
주재원 대상으로도 좀 생각하고 있어요
그래서 한국에 좀 많은 주재원들이
왔을 때 그분들이 집을 찾는다 라든지
그렇게 외국인들 대상으로 좀 비즈니스
하는 거를 좀 생각하고 있고
주재원지뿐만 아니라 뭐 처음에 이제
공항에 오면 픽업부터 해서 비자
발급해주고 통장 개설해 주고 약간
요런 서비스도 좀 생각을 하고
있거든요 세계적인
시장에 좀 도전하고 싶은 생각이
굉장히 크기 때문에
한국에서 했던 것들을 잘 정리를 해서
뉴욕시장에도 좀 접목시킬 예정이니까
제 목표는 5년 안에
그래도 뉴욕에서 성공한다라는 그런
목표가 있기 때문에
시작은 미미하지만 나중에 좀 지켜봐
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그리고
저희가
했었던 일들 있잖아요 뭐 예를 들어서
앱이라든지 빌딩들을 다 이제
전수조사해 가지고 뭐 그런
it도 접목해 가지고 좀 제작하려고
생각하고 있고 그리고 최근에는 제가
그 대중문화 기획업을 또 등록을
했어요 엔터테인먼트 지금 회사도
설립했고 웹드라마는 제가 기존에
찍었던게 있습니다 근데 그거는 아마
한 가을쯤 오픈 할 것 같아요 그래서
그거뿐만 아니라 지금 대본 쓰고 있는
것도 하나 있거든요
중개사들에 대한 얘기를 주제로 좀
이렇게 웹드라마 이런 것도 좀 꾸준히
개발할 생각이고 한 7년 정도 됐는데
뭐 빌 사람도 처음에 그랬습니다
처음에
블로그로 시작한
브랜드지만
블로그가 잘 돼서
갑자기 회사명이 됐고
처음에는 사람들이 되게 무시했었어요
블로그로 과연 이제 빌딩 사는 사람이
연락이 오겠냐 뭐 이런 무시도 많이
당하고 실제로 블로그로 이제 빌딩
계약도 했었고 그리고 유튜브도 처음에
한다고 했을 때
유튜브를 왜 하냐 이런 주변의 얘기가
많았는데 그래도 유튜브가 좀 많이
생각보다 좀 커졌고이 모든게 일단은
하고 나서 수정보원을 했거든요 그래서
어디 뭐 한 개를 정하지 않고
여기저기 도전을 좀 많이 했습니다
그러니까 지금 bsn이 여기까지 저는
왔다라고 생각을 하고
bsn이 여러 관계사들 뭐 건축사
사무소랑 건설도 섬에 설립할 때
사람들이 야 저거 뭐 저걸 너네들이
어떻게 설명하냐
종합건설 면허가 사실 딱이 되게
어렵거든요 그리고 냉정하게 얘기하면
중개업체 그리고 이제 건축사 사무소
종합건설 면허가 있는 회사는 전국에
한 곳도 없 같습니다 저희 회사가
최초에요 그래서 사실 이게 뭐
따라하기도 좀 쉽진 않고 그리고
만약에 따라한다 하더라도 이게 워낙
그런 이슈들이 많기 때문에
업체들이 하기 좀 어려운 영역이긴
하거든요 근데 저희가 그런 거 다
감안하고 우리 이름 걸고 하는 거기
때문에
앞으로도 저희는 사람들이 안 된다고
하는 걸 더 할 생각이고 생각지도
못했던 거에서 더 성과를 낼 수
있다라고 저는 생각을 합니다
앞으로 좀 bsn이 좀 어떻게
성장할지를 여러분들이 좀 지켜봐
주시면 좋을 것 같고 일단 우리가
하고 있는 일들을 좀 제가 정리를
해드리면 지금 빌딩 중계 고급주택
중개 그 다음에 빌딩 관리 건축 설계
그다음에 종합건설 그 다음에
엔터테인먼트
스터디 지금 당연 사업도 같이 하고
있거든요
앞으로 저는 여기서 더 붙여서 하고
싶어요 우리
한국
뭔가 전통적인 이런 중개업체도 이런
사업을 할 수 있다 해외로 진출할 수
있다라는 것을 좀 보여주고 싶습니다
일단 하반기 계획도 좀 말씀드리면
요번 달 이제 저희가 7월 중순에
가면
뉴욕 그 중개업체랑 mou도 체결할
생각이고 내년에는 제가 하와이도 좀
생각을 하고 있습니다 하와이에 이제
콘도 찾으시는 분들이 많아서 하와이도
좀 진출할 생각이고
웹드라마 지금 대본 쓰고 있는 것도
또 이제 제작을 할 생각이에요
하반기쯤에 이제 같이 공개를 할
생각이고 그때 이제 아마 엔터도 조금
이제 거기 출연하시는 분 위주로 이제
조금 소속해서 그분들도 좀 이렇게
브랜딩을 해줄 생각입니다 그분들은
대부분 다 이제 중개사 자격이 있는
그런 배우들 위주로
쓸 생각이고 지금 bsm 건설도
저희가 작년에
매출이 한 100억 정도 됐는데 올해
상반기에 100억이 넘었어요 그래서
지금 시장이 좋진 않지만
bsm 건설이 나름 좀 선방하고
있어서 하반기에도 100억도 추가로
해가지고 한 200억 정도 매출을 좀
했으면 좋겠습니다 중개법인도 지금
나름 되게 선방하고 있거든요 빌딩이
고급주택 눈에 띌 만한 그런
계약들이 많았고 최고가 경신한 것도
있고
연말에 또 공인중개사를 많이 또
채용할 예정인데 그때 되면 아마
인원이 중개사 비율이 되게 높아질 것
같아요 중개 법인 중에 중개사항과
우리 회사가 아마 제일 많을 것
같아요 그래서 사실 시작하기 전에
그냥 간단히 끝내려고 했는데 이게
말하다 보니까 너무 많습니다 일단이
영상을
구독자분들 어떻게 보셨는지 모르겠지만
일단은 좀 정리를 해보자면
bs에는 좀 여러 가지 도전을 좀
많이 하고 있고 남들이 안 하려는 거
하고 있고 그리고 계속 좀 변화하려고
좀 노력하고 있고 요런 모습들을
조금 지켜봐 주시면 좋을 것 같고
혹시 뭐 중간에 뭐 이렇게 제안해
주실 거라든지 뭐 이런 좀 조언해
주실 거라든지 이런 거 있으시면
언제든지 뭐
댓글이나 이런 걸 좀 남겨주시면 저희
사업하는데 좀 많이 도움이 될 것
같습니다 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다